more than 100 FEMA staff members are
deployed in the potential path of
hurricane ARMA as it moves toward the US
this morning the storm is expected to
reach South Florida by Sunday other FEMA
workers are still helping hurricane
Harvey victims in Texas and Louisiana a
lot of work to still do there so far
FEMA has approved more than one hundred
and forty eight million dollars in aid
for more than 180,000 survivors of
Harvey the agency found hotel rooms for
more than 53,000 people last week FEMA
administrator Brock long is with us now
from FEMA headquarters in Washington
Brock long it's good to see you and I'm
so sorry under these circumstances
because I know you must be thinking oh
no here we go again not deja vu but this
is a question how prepared are you
feeling what are you concerned about as
you sit here this morning well you know
my confidence is high you know we we
have a despite everything that's going
on this is what we test and train for we
have catastrophic plans obviously after
our MOA yes you know staffing patterns
could be strained but right now we are
actually operating out of a Caribbean
office we have a Caribbean office and we
office specifically located in Puerto
Rico we have staff and the Virgin
Islands as well as we for deployed
incident management teams power teams
traditional life safety use our teams
already in the state of Florida as well
ready to support so I think our staffing
levels are coming up we have over 700
people right now pre position to be able
to support our partners there are
reports that FEMA's Disaster Relief Fund
is down to its last 1 billion dollars in
that it could run out of money by Friday
can you confirm that what's the status
of your resources so you know the
president Tom Bossert the Department of
Homeland Security Secretary Duke we've
all been working together to correctly
inform the Congress to act to pass the
Supplemental and so Congress knows what
they need to do to be able to give us
the enduring authority to push forward
so there's great lines of communication
but are you out of money right now no
we're not and we're not gonna let money
get in the way of saving lives either
administrator I think one of the one of
the biggest concerns here is how much
development there's been in Florida and
Miami since andr which was
devastating in 1992 we talked about all
these cranes that are up that are only
designed to deal with a hundred and
forty five mile an hour winds how
concerned are you about all the
construction that's going on right now
and stuff that can't be taken down
before irma comes through you know I
can't speak to the number of cranes or
the amount of construction I there
obviously there's a lot of construction
that is taking place I think one of the
things that Florida had was the 2001
Building Code so hopefully a lot of the
structures that were built after 2001
where at least built to a category 3 you
know when standard within the state now
I know there's been a lot of controversy
over that that Building Code law passed
but hopefully a lot of the new
construction that was complete is at
least designed to withstand winds up to
a cat 3 I know I heard you say that
you're prepared and this is a job you do
but you certainly don't like to do it
back to back the way you have to do at
this time are there any lessons that you
learn from Harvey that you know will
make it better for you to deal with Emma
absolutely so anytime we have major
events like this we conduct exhaustive
after-action reports not only just
internal efforts to understand what we
did right versus what we could have done
better but we work with our local
partners a lot of people have no idea
how complex and busy this agency is and
part of my role is to explain it I mean
you guys mentioned the wildfires going
on we're actively engaged in providing
support to all the wildfires that are
told many of the wildfires that are
taking place around the country
we're actually reassessing our staffing
levels that other disasters across the
country we've been in 25 states helping
support other disasters before all of
this began so we're having to reassess
how we have you know our staffing
patterns in other states and how we
mobilize and we're ready to perform the
life-safety missions of irma I know you
get the latest and best information from
the National Weather Service and others
this morning where are you most worried
about in Florida well obviously they're
you know I've never put a lot of
confidence in a five-day forecast and so
what I mean by that is is that it's no
disrespect to our partners down at the
National Hurricane Center we have some
of the best meteorologists and on the
globe down there but a five-day forecast
is very hard to depict so I think that
everybody needs to be monitoring this in
the Gulf and up the East Coast you know
and watching this very carefully to see
what changes happen I never look at one
singular forecast I look at the past
three to recognize trends and what the
system is doing to make better decisions
that's really good advice about looking
at the five-day because is you know
Brocket changes on a dime it can really
good point thank you
Rock long thank you very much thank you